wann haben sie meine damen und herren
sich zum ersten mal so richtig verliebt
hat damals der blitz eingeschlagen oder
wurde aus freundschaft langsam liebe wie
auch immer es war verlieben können wir
uns auch schon war ganz gut
bloß wie es mit der liebe im alltag
weitergeht das wissen wir nicht so genau
mein heutiger gast weiß ist oder er hat
zumindest dieses buch hier geschrieben
lauf der liebe das von einem paar
erzählt dem es nach ehrungen und
wirrungen gelingt die liebe durch die
zeiten zu retten
geschrieben hat es allein die überzahl
seine philosophische bücher sind in
vielen sprachen bestseller und seine
videoclips zu philosophischen
alltagsfragen begeistern millionen mit
ihm spreche ich heute über philosophie
und liebe und darüber was diese beiden
gläser hier mit der zwei jack esther zu
tun haben
herzlich willkommen beim gewinn sank von
sich sagen sich verlieben das geht
eigentlich noch ganz einfach warum
brauchen wir denn ab suite inder oder
partner vermittlungsagenturen nun liebe
ist immer kompliziert
eine der großen gefahren ist die annahme
liebe sei einfach oder entstehen
natürlich es ist erstaunlich in wie
vielen lebensbereichen wir uns ausbilden
müssen sei es um fliegen ein unternehmen
führen oder einen chirurgischen eingriff
vornehmen zu können
geht es aber um liebe meinen wir zu
wissen was zu tun ist
das ist verrückt wenn ich sagen würde
ich fliege einen airbus a380 nach new
york ohne das gelernt zu haben
würde man mich für verrückt halten doch
wir lassen zu dass menschen aller
generationen sich verlieben beziehungen
eingehen und heiraten ohne die geringste
ahnung zu haben wie das geht
liebe ist kein gefühl liebe ist eine
fähigkeit die wir systematisch erlernen
sollten das klingt sie unruhe würde ich
ihnen sagen verlieben sie sich nicht
sondern gehen sie zur schule und lernen
sie wie man liebt würden sie wohl
protestieren wie schrecklich ich will
einfach mit dem herzen leben wir
reagieren so war wie eine romantische
vorstellung von
aber damit zerstören wir sie erst wenn
wir unsere romantischen vorstellungen
über bord werfen können wir richtig zu
liegen beginnen
denn die idee die liebe die in unserer
gesellschaft vorherrscht zerstört die
liebe die wir erleben möchten
darüber werden wir noch sprechen über
diese romantische idee der liebe
bleiben wir noch kurz beim sich
verlieben warum denken denn so viele das
hat etwas zu tun mit dem schicksal man
hat auch diese vorstellungen es gibt da
mister oder miss right die da draußen
warten und man muss sich einfach
begegnen und dann schlägt der blitz ein
interessanterweise sind wir nicht frei
in der wahl unserer liebespartner wir
verlieben uns in spezifische
charaktertypen und meistens verstehen
wir gar nicht warum wir sagen ich habe
diese person in einer bar kennengelernt
und plötzlich ist es passiert das war
schicksal schlägt man uns eine andere
person vor protestieren wir die kommt
nicht in frage mit ihr stimmt etwas aber
wir können nicht sagen was wir wissen
nicht warum wir gewisse menschen lieben
und andere unmöglich leben können
diesbezüglich glaube ich will
psychoanalytiker dass die
anziehungskraft die gewisse menschen auf
uns ausüben mit unserer kindheit zu tun
hat als kinder haben wir zum ersten mal
live erlebt wenn wir erwachsen werden
erinnern wir uns wie wir als kinder
geliebt wurden und wir verlieben uns im
menschen die uns an jener personen die
wir als erste in unserer kindheit
geliebt haben
es überrascht daher nicht dass viele
verliebte einander baby nennen auch wenn
das seltsam klingt und das erklärt warum
wir oft eine schlechte partnerwahl
treffen denn die menschen die wir als
kinder lebten waren nicht perfekt
vielleicht war die mutter ein wenig der
presse vor der vater war immer unterwegs
oder hat er ein aufbrausendes
temperament als erwachsene gehen wir
dann beziehungen ein mit menschen die
immer weg sind ein aufbrausendes
temperament haben oder depressiv sind
unsere freunde fragen uns warum bist du
mit dieser person zusammen warum nicht
mit jemanden der dir gut tut
doch wir können nicht zugeben dass sie
recht haben
denn wir gehen von der landkarte der
liebe aus die uns als kinder zur
verfügung stand wir sind nicht frei in
der wahl unseres partner auch nicht
besonders schmeichelhaft wenn man sich
dann überlegt dass man selber gewählt
wurde weil man sie ähnlich ist die
eigene schwiegermutter oder wieder
eigene schwiegervater sicher eine
schwierige sehen sie in der liebe
erleben wir auch demütigungen
das sollte uns nicht beleidigen wir
kennen komplimente wie mir gefällt eine
art du bist so kompetent wie meine
mutter oder du bist so verlässlich wie
mein vater es gibt also gute gründe
warum wir uns im menschen vergeben die
uns an die positiven seiten unserer
eltern oder andere bezugspersonen aus
unserer kindheit erinnern
schwierig wird es wenn wir uns nur in
menschen verlieben die uns unglücklich
machen viele menschen erfahren in der
liebe nicht nur glück sondern oft viel
leid das ihnen vertraut ist das erklärt
warum gewisse leute x-mal ihre
beziehungen abbrechen und sich immer
wieder in die gleichen typen verlieren
die umstehenden verstehe nicht warum sie
sich immer für partner entscheiden die
kein geld haben sie schikanieren oder
auf die kein verlass ist etwas vom
ersten was wir tun müssen wenn wir uns
verlieben ist unsere liebes landkarte zu
analysieren und zu verstehen warum wir
gerade diesen menschen liegen welche
beziehungen uns geprägt haben wir alle
sind ein wenig verrückt wenn es um liebe
geht
doch die idee wir sein engel könnten uns
einfach zum candle-light-dinner
verabreden und alles sei perfekt ist
falsch denn wir tragen unser emotionales
gepäck aus der vergangenheit mit uns ja
denn wenn ein mann und eine frau sich zu
einem date treffen bringen sie ihre
ganze vergangenheit mit sich ihre
familien ihre kindheit alles ist präsent
das größte geschenk das sie ihren
geliebten machen können ist dass sie ihm
aufgrund ihrer selbst kenntnis sagen
können wir sie sind
nicht ob sie gern tennis spielen oder
skifahren oder welcher konfitüre sie
lieben sondern was sie gefühlsmäßig
ausmacht denn wir sind alle ein wenig
schwierig und je besser wir uns selbst
verstehen desto besser können wir den
menschen den wir lieben auf das
zusammensein mit uns vorbereiten
es wäre toll wenn sie beim ersten date
mit einem potenziellen partner sagen
können ich bin ein wenig verrückt und
zwar in diesen fünf punkten wie sieht es
bei dir aus und ihr sagt ich bin auch
ein wenig verrückt hier sind meine 5 das
wäre eine herrliche intelligente
großzügige offenbarung dessen wie wir
wirklich sind
anstatt dass beide meinen ich bin
perfekt und du bist es auch und die
beziehung beginnt mit großen hoffnungen
die an die realität zerbrechen
wir brauchen keine perfekten
liebespartner wir brauchen partner die
uns vor ihren unvollkommenheiten warnen
und zwar in guten zeiten auf ruhige art
bevor die beziehung zu viel schaden
erlitten hat das ist eine der großen
herausforderungen die liebe dich
verlieben gehört es doch auch ein ideal
zu haben und von etwas zu träumen und
nicht bereit sich damit zu befassen
welche marken das gegenüber haben könnte
sie können jemanden lieben ihn
respektieren und von ihm begeistert sein
ohne in ihm einen engel zu sehen
[Musik]
mit gutem grund sind die engel im himmel
und nicht auf erden
wenn mir ein freund sagt ich habe mich
verliebt sie ist perfekt leuchtet bei
mir sofort ein warnlicht auf das kann
nicht sein
er hat sie noch nicht richtig
kennengelernt nur menschen die wir nicht
kennen sind wir uns perfekt wenn sie
jemanden im supermarkt oder am flughafen
sehen denken sie vielleicht wie nett er
aussieht er muss perfekt sein aber sie
kennen ihn nicht jeder hat seine
schwierigen seiten die man erst mit der
zeit entdeckt jeder offenbart sich ein
wenig als albtraum wenn man ihn näher
kennenlernen
sicher haben unsere liebespartner nette
und liebenswerte seiten aber wir sollten
großzügig sein und ihnen zugestehen dass
sie nicht perfekt
sein müssen denn wir alle sind nur
menschen mit kindern
wenn jemand sagt ich bekomme ein kind
und es wird perfekt sein und beste
manieren haben fragt man sich instinktiv
was passiert wenn das kind mal mich
diese vorstellung entspricht gute eltern
sagen manchmal wird mein kind müde und
folgsam oder wütend sein
ich liebe es trotzdem denn es ist mein
kind das ist für mich echte liebe liebe
ist nicht die bewunderung von perfektion
liebe ist die zuneigung für einen
menschen mit all seinen
unvollkommenheiten lieben sie also
jemanden trotz seiner ecken und kanten
ist das wahre liebe
jetzt sind wir eigentlich fast schon bei
der liebe auch wie sie gelingen kann was
man sozusagen vielleicht sich ansehen
muss was man aushalten muss wenn man
zusammen bleiben möchte wenn ihr noch
einmal zum sich verlieben zurückgehen
gibt es ja auch die situation dass man
sehr unglücklich verliebt ist und da
stellt sich die frage wie der liebe ein
bisschen auf die sprünge helfen dürfen
oder ob wir das schicksal machen lassen
müssen und diese frage stellt sich auch
das philosophische gedanken experiment
die liebesspiele wir haben dieses
gedankenexperiment animiert im rahmen
unserer serie philosoph iks diese
philosophie können sie übrigens immer
noch auf unserer website sehen das sind
alle diese gedankenexperimente gesammelt
vorhanden
schauen wir uns diese liebe spielemarken
einsamer
chemielehrer 230 das wirst du die
experimente laufen super doch die
letzten wochen kannst du nichts anderes
mehr denken als an lisa die neue
englischlehrerin an deiner sprung
sie ist wunderschön witzig klug
selbstbewusst und singe kurz du bist
unsterblich verliebt leider aber
ignoriert dich seine angebetete in einer
schlaflosen nacht kommt er plötzlich
eine idee
es sollte doch möglich sein eine liebes
pille herzustellen die ein feuer der
liebe entfacht das nie wieder löscht
dieser hätte endlich nur noch augen für
dich die nächsten wochen verbringst du
nacht für nacht im labor bist du endlich
die liebes formel gefunden hast
[Musik]
am nächsten tag beim café sitzt ihr euch
zufällig gegenüber
da ergibt sich der perfekte moment um
lisa die pilger unterzuschieben
du weißt ihr beide wert glücklich bis an
ihr lebensende
was tust du steckst du ihr die liebe
spiele ins töpfchen na klar auf jeden
fall auch mit einem neuen haarschnitt
oder einem sinnlichen parfüm versuchte
lisas gefühle zu beeinflussen liebes
pille ist nur ein anderes mittel um
diese für dich zu gewinnen
oder zögert du weil sich lisa ganz frei
für dich entscheiden soll
aber hast du dich frei für lisa
entschieden
die liebe erwischte einen es ist keine
freie entscheidung
und schließlich dieser sehen sich genau
wie du nach intensiven liebesgefühlen
sie würde die pille vermutlich auch
freiwillig nehmen
also was tust du nun interessanterweise
gibt es in diesem film nur eine liebes
pille lisa soll sich also verlieben aber
auch der chemie lehrer braucht eine
pille nämlich um zu vergessen was ihr
getan hat denn ohne diese pille wird
lisas liebe zu ihm unglaubhaft
eines der größten probleme in der liebe
ist das gefühl dass unser partner nicht
wirklich uns liebt stellen sie sich eine
schöne frau vor in die sich alle
verlieben
an einem gewissen punkt fragt sie einen
ihrer verehrer liebst du mich oder nur
mein aussehen
oder nehmen sie einen berühmten
tennisspieler gefragt seine partnerin
irgendwann liebst du mich oder mein
talent als tennisspieler oder ein
reicher mann fragt eine frau liebst du
mich oder meine fähigkeit geld zu machen
letztendlich wollen wir nicht wegen
äußerlichkeiten geliebt werden
paradoxerweise versuchen wir aber oft
genau damit die liebe von jemanden zu
erlangen werden wir dann aber nur
deswegen geliebt sind wir keineswegs
erfreut
schuld daran ist unsere kindheit als wir
zum ersten mal lieber erfuhren waren wir
etwa so gross schrien seien schrecklich
aus hatten kein geld und sagte nichts
interessantes trotzdem liebte uns jemand
und tief in uns drin suchen wir diese
bedingungslose liebe die sich nicht nach
auffälligkeiten richtet die chemie
lehrer hat lisa mit chemie dazu gebracht
ihn zu lieben und das wird er nie
vergessen
mitten in der nacht fragte sich liebt
sie mich oder nur eine idee von mir weil
sie diese chemischen substanzen
eingenommen hat bei cameco darauf kommen
wir gleich noch zu sprechen aber noch
einmal zum vorherigen punkt was wir das
denn heißen wenn sie jetzt sagen wir
lieben eine person nicht wegen ihrer
eigenschaften sondern als person was ist
die person ohne eigenschaften ist die
person ohne ihre positiven attribute am
anfang einer beziehung lieben wir
jemanden für seine stärken
aber niemand will nur deswegen geliebt
werden wir wollen dass man uns mit oder
trotz unserer schwächen liebt das ist
das paradoxe gehen wir zu einem date
sehen wir umwerfend aus soll die
beziehung aber funktionieren muss unser
partner uns auch in einem alten pyjama
gerne haben wenn ihr partner sie auch in
ihrem alten pyjama entzückend findet
zeigt er dass er sie wirklich liebt
müssen sie viel make-up auftragen und
ihren partner mit schönen worten
umgarnen ist das nicht liebe sondern
performance und das wollen wir auch
gerade das beispiel mit dem baby zeigt
doch auch dass wir in dem moment in dem
wir ein kind kriegen werden die
überschwemmt von hormon oxytocin
überschwemmt uns und wir können gar
nicht anders aus dieses kleine bündel zu
lieben und sie haben selber gesagt
kleine babys städten überhaupt nicht
besonders hübsch ich sehe das anders
aber gibt sie werden vielleicht mann
frau unterschied aber grundsätzlich kann
man ja mal sagen meistens also doch
normalerweise liebt man das eigene kind
wegen der hormonellen lage das heißt so
anders ist das doch nicht
nein denn es gibt gute gründe warum wir
unsere kinder lieben
zuerst einmal glaube ich nicht dass
liebe nur eine chemische reaktion ist
die die nicht verstehen können
wir müssen uns in acht nehmen vor der
idee liebe sei etwas verrücktes dass man
nicht verstehen kann
nein wir verlieben uns aus logischen
gründen vielleicht in das bizarre gründe
jemand erinnert sie an ihre mutter oder
ihren onkel
aber es sind logische gründe ich glaube
nicht an die theorie von amors pfeil der
einen trifft ohne dass man weiß warum
man sich gerade
diese person verliebt es gibt eine logik
dahinter
auch wenn es in diesem trickfilm und
chemie und neurosen geht ist es ein
romantischer film die liga seine art
trick oder blind eyes darstellt und dazu
ermuntert den anderen blind vor liebe zu
machen da die hormone sowieso verrückt
spielen
das sehe ich nicht so
liebe ist offen für erforschungen und
entsteht aus guten gründen
man muss sie sich nicht mit tricks
erschwindeln es geht darum die liebe zu
verstehen sich und den partner zu
verstehen dann wächst die liebe von
allein
ich halte nichts von der idee lebe sei
ein zaubertrank liebe ist bewunderung
sensibilität und zärtlichkeit und
entsteht aus logischen gründen trotzdem
haben ja ärzte bis ins 18 jahrhundert
hinein geglaubt dass es solche auf
riesigen tränke gibt das hat sich auch
niedergeschlagen der literatur denken
dir an shakespeares sommernachtstraum in
dem sich sogar titania einen ganzen
esels kopf verliebt weil die tropfen in
ihren augen sie glauben machen dass sie
dennis kopf liegt oder auch tristan und
isolde
also diese ganzen liebesgeschichten
welche sehnsucht steckt denn dahinter
dass wir uns einfach ein chemisches
mittel einfach leiden müssen und dann
können wir die liebe kontrollieren
das sind vor allem solche
liebesgeschichten die unsere chancen auf
ein glückliches liebesleben zerstören
die geschichte der westeuropäischen
liebes literatur liefert katastrophale
beispiele dafür wie wir leben sollten
nehmen sie shakespeares romeo und julia
diese liebe zwischen einem 16 jährigen
und einer 13 jährigen die in einem
doppelten suizid endet das ist verrückt
aber wir finden es so romantisch doch
das ist nicht romantisch es ist auch
keine liebe es ist krank die beiden
hätte man psychiatrisch behandeln sollen
diese geschichte ist weder romantisch
noch hat sie mit liebe zu tun
wir beginnen erst zu verstehen was liebe
wirklich ist und ich finde psychologen
psychoanalytiker und philosophen leisten
einen großartigen beitrag um
herauszufinden was in die liebe wirklich
vor sich geht
die verrückte liebe in hollywoodfilmen
und literatur wie die von shakespeare
mag schon sein aber wie schokolade die
viele über alles lieben wohl 7
nicht guttut schaden uns auch solche
geschichten die liebesgeschichten die
wir kennen ruinieren unsere chancen auf
ein erfülltes liebesleben
genau deshalb habe ich diesen roman
geschrieben
ich wollte eine andere art von liebes
geschichte schreiben einen anti romeo
und julia roman zwei menschen lernen
sich kennen verlieben sich und bauen
eine beziehung auf aber ihre
liebesgeschichte ist untypisch sie ist
anti romantisch bricht jedoch eine lanze
für die wahre liebe
denn ich glaube an die liebe an die
glückliche liebe aber ich denke sie wird
völlig falsch verstanden
dagegen wollte ich etwas tun lassen sie
mich noch einmal auf die liebesspiele
zurückkommen es gibt ja durchaus
philosophen die das ein bisschen anders
sehen denken die an julien sawall s co
er gehört der strömung der des traums
humanismus an er glaubt dass wir die
natürlichen grenzen des menschen
sprengen sollten und über uns
hinauswachsen die menschheit weiter
entwickeln und er hat diese idee dass es
durchaus eine gute idee sein könnte wenn
es sie denn gibt und wissenschaftler
glauben wir sind nahe dran an
entsprechende liebe spiele zu entwickeln
oder zumindest die hormone genau
zusammen zu stellen so dass wir uns
immer mal wieder mit einem aphrodisiakum
helfen können
liebesbeziehungen wieder anzukurbeln uns
wieder neu zu verlieben wenn es sowas
gelbes hauptschule in seoul es gut
annehmen dass mit bestem gewissen
es wird uns helfen glücklicher zu sein
interessanterweise träumen die leute
immer von dingen die es bereits gibt
wie die virtuelle realität man schwärmt
davon wie man brillen aufsetzen und
andere welten entdecken kann
aber haben sie nicht auch schon im bett
gelegen die augen geschlossen und andere
welten gesehen das gilt ohne
spezialbrille
wir brauchen auch keine liebe spielen
nur etwas sensibilität und
kommunikationsfähigkeit gehen sie mit
ihrem partner an einen ruhigen ort
halten sie ihn an den händen und fragen
sie wie steht es um unsere beziehung
haben wir in letzter zeit genug
ausgetauscht
das ist die liebe spiele es geht auch
ohne chemie
wir haben die möglichkeit des dialogs
wir können kommunizieren der grund warum
die liebe von paaren erlischt ist oft
ärgern
insgeheim ärgert sich ein partner über
den anderen
nicht dass man ihn an schreien wollte es
ist ein stiller ärger weil man sich
nicht verstanden oder verletzt fühlt der
herz strom die liebe ist blockiert
deshalb haben die beiden keinen sex mehr
sie ertragen keine berührung weil sie
eingeschnappt sind du hast mir nicht
zugehört nein du hast mir nicht zugehört
sie führen einen stillen krieg solche
paare brauchen keine liebes viele
sondern ein wenig gemeinsame zeit um die
blockierten liebes kanäle wieder zum
fließen zu bringen
vielen betrieben sie sagen jetzt das
brauchen sie nicht sie brauchen keine
liebe spinne wäre es denn falsch sie
zunehmend finden sie liebe sollte arbeit
sein oder sagen sie liebe nur mit der
pille wird einfach nie funktionieren
wenn sie eine liebe spiele verkaufen
stellen sie sich vor sie sagen zu
jemanden ich gebe dir eine pille und du
schreibst das beste buch der welt du
kannst es aber auch ohne versuchen das
erstere wollen die meisten nicht denn es
wäre nicht ausdruck ihrer selbst stellen
sie sich vor sie sagen zu einem kind ich
mache deine hausaufgaben du wirst damit
brillieren bekommst zehn von zehn
möglichen punkten ein ehrliches kind
sagt nein das will ich selber machen
denn schlussendlich wollen wir unser
eigenes leben leben unser eigenes leid
ertragen
ähnlich ist es mit dir glücksspiele ein
gutes leben ist ein leben in dem wir
leiden wenn uns leid widerfährt und
indem wir glücklich sind wenn uns das
glück begegnet ein leben in dem wir uns
die liebe andere verdienen und nicht
erzwingen
es ist wunderschön wenn uns jemand liebt
für etwas das wir getan haben
er trickste liebe ist keine richtige
liebe sprechen wir über ihr buch sie
haben jetzt schon mehrmals erwähnt ihr
sind zwei figuren miteinander unterwegs
rabl und kersten
sie sind zusammen in dieser ganzen
geschichte der liebe unterwegs von sich
verlieben sich ver heiraten kinder
kriegen die ganzen seitensprünge und so
weiter die ganze geschichte ist hier
drin
und sie haben es schon angetönt sie
sagen das große problem ist dass muss
dieses paar auch lernen dass der roma
und die cis muss eine schlechte
vorstellung der liebe ist was genau ist
falsch an romantizismus und wo
worin besteht der romantizismus gaukelt
uns vor liebe sei einfach wahre liebe
sein gefühl dass man plötzlich für
jemanden empfinde und dass genügend
stark sein haben uns durch das ganze
leben zu tragen
man müsse nur die richtige person finden
dann sei alles perfekt
man habe ein vollkommenes liebesleben
und wunderbare kinder die einfach zu
erzielen seien
man streite sich nie und so bleibe es
bis zu unserem todestag
die meisten wissen dass das nicht stimmt
doch sie fühlen sich deshalb schuldig
traurig und allein denn die meisten
wünschen sich eine langfristige
liebesbeziehung
aber die liebesgeschichten die wir
kennen gehe nicht über die ersten zwei
monate hinaus alle popsongs und filme
handeln von der ersten verliebtheit
ich wollte ein buch schreiben das die
liebe über eine lange zeit betrachtet
und aufzeigen dass liebespartner gewisse
fähigkeiten erlernen müssen um sich
verstehen zu koennen
das buch handelt also von zwei menschen
die sich lieben aber nicht wissen wie
das geht und sie machen schreckliche
oder sagen wir unangenehme zeiten durch
relativ normal
ich sollte die zuschauer warnen das ist
ein langweiliges buch es ist nicht für
jedermann
wenn sie explosive bücher voller
schießereien und dramatik lieben dann
ist das nichts für sie nein es passiert
nichts es ist total langweilig aber wenn
sie gerne menschen analysieren und die
liebe genau unter die lupe nehmen kommen
sie auf ihre rechnung denn das liebe ich
wann immer ich mit meinen freunden rede
möchte ich beziehungen verstehen und das
buch ist eine mikro analyse vieler
momente irgend liebesleben ein beispiel
am anfang die beziehung merkte man dass
er oft schmoldt das finde ich sehr
interessant so was passiert genau wenn
man schmoldt faszinierend ist dass wir
nur wegen menschen schmalen denen wir
vertrauen und von denen wir
warten dass sie uns verstehen es aber
aus irgendeinem grund nicht tun wenn man
jemanden liebt denkt man er oder sie
müsse einen voll und ganz verstehen
sie gehen zum beispiel auf eine party
das passiert uns sind womöglich ein
wenig verstimmt
ihr partner fragt sie stimmt etwas nicht
und sie verneinen
doch er investiert sagt mir was los ist
und sie verneinen aber die partner lässt
nicht locker kommt schon erklärt mir
doch sie wären abkommen nach hause gehen
ins badezimmer und schlagen die tür zu
der partner klopft an die tür habe ich
dich ärgert sag es mir doch sie rücken
nicht damit heraus denn als romantikerin
sind sie überzeugt je liebespartner
müsste ihre seele lesen können ihre
seelen würden ohne worte kommunizieren
wenn sie ihm also erklären müssen warum
sie verstimmt sind hieße das dass er sie
nicht liebt sie glauben wahre liebe
zeige sich darin dass man sich ohne
worte versteht das wollen uns die
romantiker glauben machen
doch natürlich ist das unsinn leider
kann niemand von uns gedanken lesen und
weil wir das nicht können geht es in die
liebe etwas langweiliges zu lernen wie
auch mein paar einsehen muss wir müssen
einander erklären was in uns vorgeht und
warum wir verstimmt sind sie kommen
nicht darum herum zu kommunizieren
das mag langweilig sein ist aber sehr
romantisch im wahren sinn des wortes und
sie räumen ja mit ganz vielen solchen
vorurteilen aufzuräumen zb auch damit
auf dass man einander ja immer wieder
sagt wirklich zu lieben heißt einander
einfach zu nehmen wie man isst man
sollte sich nicht verändern wollen und
soll sich einfach gegenseitig auch
zitieren sie sagen nein danke natürlich
soll man sich verändern das hat mich
überrascht das ist interessant denn wie
sie sagen gibt es diese starke idee
wenig lief muss alles an mir mögen wenn
wir ehrlich sind müssen wir zugeben dass
wir nicht perfekt sind wir haben alle
unsere macken doch liebespartner müssen
nicht alles voneinander akzeptieren
wir sollten ein umfeld schaffen in dem
wir die andere person gewissermaßen zu
erziehen versuchen damit sie die beste
version ihrer selbst werden kann
und sie sollte dasselbe mit uns tun sie
könnte uns zum beispiel sagen du
sprichst ein wenig laut oder deine
geschichten sind ein wenig langweilig
und wir könnten zu ihr sagen du bist so
komisch sehr liebevoll sollte ein paar
sich auf solche dinge aufmerksam machen
das klingt vielleicht seltsam und oft
entsteht streit weil einer der partner
in anderen auf einen makel hingewiesen
hat das problem ist dass es uns so
schlecht gelingt in liebesdingen sind
wir schlechte lehrer und auch schlechte
schüler denn wir haben die romantische
idee in die liebe gebe es nichts zu
lernen der andere müsse uns akzeptieren
wie wir sind
zudem sind wir schlechte lehrer weil wir
gestresst sind
gute lehrer sind gelassen sie gehen die
dinge ruhig an und lassen sich nicht
stressen
unter anderem weil es für sie nicht
zwingend ist verstanden zu werden wir
jedoch wollen von unseren partnern
unbedingt verstanden werden deshalb sind
wir so genervt und schreien wenn du das
handtuch nochmals auf dem boden wirfst
drehe ich durch
wir glauben dir partner zerstöre unser
leben wir denken wir hätten einen
idioten geheiratet und werden hysterisch
und ihr partner fühlt sich gedemütigt
und lernt natürlich nichts gibt man dem
gegenüber das gefühl er sei nicht ok
wird dir nie auf einen höheren man muss
liebevoll sagen was einen stört und
gleichzeitig auch lernfähig sein
vielleicht weist uns der andere auf
wichtige dinge hin die wir lernen
sollten
doch oft sitzt sich ein paar mit
verschränkten armen stuhr gegenüber er
sagt du musst dich ändern und sie sagt
ich muss gar nichts und wir haben diese
schreckliche dynamiken dir die beiden
nichts voneinander annehmen und in dem
teufelskreis stecken bleiben sie sind
selber vater von zwei jungen
unverheiratet ist es dasselbe für sie
die kinder zu erziehen die die frau zu
erziehen
es ist faszinierend denn meine frau und
ich sind so liebevoll zu den kindern
aber weniger nett zueinander
guten tagen schon aber nicht immer
faszinierend ist warum als mein älterer
sohn noch sehr klein war war er oft
umgezogen
ich kam müde und gestresst von der
arbeit nach hause kochte für ihn und
stellte ihm einen teller mit schnitzel
kartoffeln und brokkoli auf den tisch
und der damals zweijährige fegte den
teller zu boden
interessanterweise sagte ich nicht zu
ihm böses kind du weißt doch was sich
für einen harten schrecklichen tag hatte
und jetzt dass ich hasse dich ich dachte
vielmehr hammer kleiner vielleicht ist
er müde oder ihr zahnd oder wie er ist
eifersüchtig auf seinen bruder
ich suchte nach entschuldigungen für
sein schlechtes benehmen
doch so gehen erwachsene nicht
miteinander um das erlebt auch mal ein
paar im buch sie sind sehr lieb zu ihren
kindern aber sehr streng zueinander
er denkt nicht vielleicht hatte sie
einen schlechten tag und sie denkt nicht
vielleicht meint er nicht was er sagt
wir sind unglaublich streng mit unseren
liebespartner ich denke eines der
geheimnisse die liebe ist es zu
versuchen was nicht immer möglich ist
den partner zu behandeln als wäre er
zwei jahre alt nicht immer aber in
diesem bereich denn kinder lieben wir
sehr intuitiv das war nicht immer so
aber wir haben gelernt unsere kinder zu
lieben
vor 100 jahren hätte man ein kind das
sein essen zu boden wird geschlagen oder
in den regen hinaus geschickt um ihm
eine lektion zu erteilen
heute wissen wir dass das nicht richtig
ist aber mit unseren partnern sind wir
sehr streng
ein beispiel dass sie auch bringen dass
viele paare wahrscheinlich auf den ort
erkennen ist ihr paar geht in ein
möbelhaus und es möchte gerne gläser
kaufen
sie hätten gerne dieses modell er hätte
gerne dieses modell
wir sind natürlich stolz darauf dass das
glas was sie im buch erwähnen genau das
gleiche ist die unsere studio gläser
stimmt und das sind die gleichen gläser
wie buchstäblich ich habe versucht auf
jeden fall diese beiden gläser sie dass
er das das resultat ist sie gehen nach
hause ohne gläser schmollen wie kleine
kinder
ich habe schon verstanden was man tun
solltest dich einzufügen sich gleich zu
überlegen vielleicht hat der einen
schlechten tag oder er sollte vielleicht
ich sagen naja gefällt mir zwar nicht
aber so schlimm ist das jetzt auch
wieder nicht aber ganz konkret was wäre
denn die lösung man steht da und man
merkt er dann förmlich wie man um geduld
wird es ist meistens auch nicht so eine
nette umbaus in einem möbelhaus es ist
irgendwie genau der ort muss ich ganz
viele paare in die haare kriegen aber
wie genau was genau sollte das paar
interessanterweise beginnen viele
streitereien von paaren damit dass beide
denken das ist zu dumm und so unwichtig
um sich deswegen zu streiten
sie werden sie ungeduldig und sagen ich
habe studiert ich bin intelligent ich
bin ich wie meine eltern ich bin
sensibel daher streite ich mich nicht
wegen ein paar blöden gläser
das ist gefährlich denn nichts ist zu
klein und niemand ist zu intelligent um
nicht deswegen einen riesen streit vom
zaun zu brechen
wir sind alle irgendwie verrückt und
müssen wissen dass die meinung einfache
dinge könnten uns nichts anhaben ein
feind der liebe ist auch daran ist die
literatur schuld in romantischen
geschichten haben liebende politische
probleme oder die eltern sind liegen
ihre beziehung oder es herrscht krieg
und sie werden getrennt
unsinn die wahren probleme eines paars
kreisel um dinge wie liegt das handtuch
am boden oder ist es aufgehängt soll ich
meine zähne so oder so putzen sie hat
die fernbedienung des fernsehers das
klingt idiotisch aber das ist der punkt
wir sind nicht darauf vorbereitet dass
uns kleinigkeiten so große probleme
bereiten
deshalb werden wir ungeduld nicht wegen
der schwierigkeiten an sich sondern weil
wir nicht mit ihnen gerechnet haben und
sie deshalb nicht einplanen
niemand sagt heute gehe ich gläser
einkaufen mit meiner lebenspartnerin und
das ist eine der größten
herausforderungen für uns es ist so
schwierig wie einen
zu erklimmen oder violine spielen zu
lernen deswegen müssen wir genügend zeit
dafür haben und liebevoll zueinander
sein
ein paar geht ins warenhaus und sie sagt
das haben wir in fünf sekunden mir
gefallen diese gläser die sind schön und
er mir gefallen diese besser
komm schon wir haben keine zeit nehmen
wir diese nein diese und sie werden
immer hysterischer und denken der andere
sei unmöglich
sie sind zu streng miteinander sie haben
nicht die richtigen bücher gelesen wie
flaubert es madame bovary ihre
beziehungen scheiterten weil sie die
falschen romane gelesen hatte ich
wünschte mein paar könnte meinen roman
lesen
anders gesagt die beiden würden sanft
darauf hingewiesen dass es völlig normal
ist wegen kleinigkeiten zu streiten in
der literatur des neunzehnten
jahrhundert streitet sich niemand wegen
der wäsche
man erfährt kaum wir die wäsche macht
heutige paare streiten sich oft darum
wer für die wäsche zuständig ist aber
wir sind nicht großzügig und sehe nicht
dass dies zu den herausforderungen der
liebe gehört großzügigkeit ist eine
wunderschöne eigenschaften die ich sehe
schon auf welchen punkt sie raus wollen
überzeugt nicht auch in vielem aber es
gibt ja auch diese menschen die
unglaublich großzügig sind mit allem und
allen und die immer nachgeben die dann
sofort sagen ach so du magst du über
dieses glas ja eigentlich spielt es mir
keine rolle dann lasst uns das hier
nehmen auch wenn sie hässlich finden und
das kann ein jahr andauern
doch auch mit der zeit ein bisschen
nervös machen weil man denkt man hat
doch auch ein standpunkt man soll auch
mal seine meinung durchsetzen können sie
hier kann es auch übertreiben damit auf
jeden fall
es gibt einen riesigen unterschied
zwischen großzügigen menschen und
solchen die immer ja sagen und nachgeben
die wollen ja menschen geben die
authentisch sind und ihre eigenen
interessen und ihre persönlichkeit haben
wenn jemand immer ja sagt ist dies
unerträglich und auch gefährlich
manchmal müssen wir ein nein hören
und etwas vom schönsten was ein
liebespartner tun kann
das passiert auch im buch ist einander
zunächst wenn ihr partner sie liebevoll
und zärtlich nett ist das sehr schön
denn es zeigt zwei dinge erstens dass
sie einen liebevollen partner haben und
zweitens was noch wichtiger ist er hat
etwas negatives in ihrer persönlichkeit
entdeckt und daraus einen witz gemacht
anstatt zu sagen du kannst dich nie
entscheiden nennt er sie hamlet nun
hamlet was hast du entschieden
und beide müssen lachen wir können über
uns selbst lachen
eine wichtige frage die sich jeder
stellen kann lautet wofür möchte ich von
meinem idealen liebespartner gedeckt
werden was mich betrifft würde meine
ideale liebes partnerin mich
wahrscheinlich necken weil ich zu viel
denken und mich zu viel mit büchern
befassen
sie würde wohl sagen kommen die küche
sokrates und wische den boden auf denn
wir wissen dass wir alle bereiche haben
in denen wir übertreiben sei es dass wir
zu sportlich sind wenn ich die mal nicht
immer dran wir dass es geht doch auch
den moment wenn jetzt jemand kennt sagen
den kommunen sokrates wir gehen in die
küche würde ich auch verstehen wenn ich
sagen die moment mal das ist gerade
wichtig hier was ich sage mach dich
nicht
natürlich auf jeden fall
ich wollte einfach sagen dass eine
gewisse art von humor in die liebe
unglaublich wichtig ist und dass
entdeckt auch ein paar
denn wenn man ein paar jahre mit
jemandem zusammenlebt ist es einfach zu
denken ich habe eine idiotin geheiratet
hier hat sie wieder da hat er erneut in
kann man nur so dumm sein wenn man
komödien anschaut und ihre geschichte
analysiert sieht man dass die meisten
helden oder heldinnen irgendwie idioten
sind
mir kommen vor allem angelsächsische in
den sinn john cleese sind vor ort die
towers das hin vollidioten treffe man
sie im realen leben würde man denken
mein gott aber genial an comedy shows
ist dass wir über diese typen lachen
müssen
dadurch werden sie zum liebenswerten
idioten
es ist ein großer fortschritt wenn sie
ihren partner nicht als idioten sondern
als liebenswerten idioten sehen
das ist fantastisch ein erfolg in der
liebe wir müssten zur schule gehen und
lernen wie wir unsere liebespartner als
liebenswerte idioten behandelt kommen
wir zu diesem top 4 der hat auch seine
funktionen eine schwierigkeit ist es ja
und auch davon handelt das buch die
liebe auch wach zu halten was die
leidenschaft anbelangt die sexualität
wach zu halten die ganze idee der
anziehung der attraktivität man kann
nicht voneinander lassen das alles
schläft mit der zeit ein sie sagen
selber ein stück weit ist das tragisch
eckart von hirschhausen ein komiker der
hat mal gesagt wenn wir in den ersten
beiden jahren eine liebesbeziehung eine
murmel im gras legen würden
für jedes mal dem ihr sex haben und dann
hab den dritten jahr für jedes mal eine
murmel rausnehmen würden dann würde das
glas bei den meisten paaren sich nie
wieder leben ein trauriges bild was ist
denn dagegen zu tun
oder müssen wir gar nichts dagegen tun
häufig sehen sie es gibt jene die sagen
das sexuelle interesse sterbe aus
mysteriösen gründen wie sie gemerkt
haben wenig gegen solche mysteriösen
geschichten die uns weismachen wollen
dass wir uns grundlos erleben oder
grundlos keinen sex mehr
ich bin philosoph genug um zu sagen
schauen wir dass genauer oft beobachten
wir dass ein paar nicht aus fehlendem
interesse keinen sex mehr hat sondern
wegen emotionaler blockaden und wie
vorher sagte weil ein partner wütend
irritiert oder gelangweilt ist was ist
sex sex ist ein moment größter
verletzlichkeit sie geben sich jemandem
hin und sind daher sehr viel
fühlen sie sich aber durch ihren partner
verletzt womöglich in einem ganz anderen
bereich sei es dass er auf einem sofa
beharrt dass ihnen nicht gefällt sei es
dass sie einen verwandten besuchen will
den sie nicht sehen wollen oder er hat
die küche nicht aufgeräumte er sollte
wenn uns aber jemand wehgetan hat wollen
wir uns ihm gegenüber nicht verletzlich
machen
nur gelingt es uns nicht das zu sagen
wir merken dass uns nicht nach sex ist
geben aber nicht so dass wir eigentlich
wütend sind so funktioniert unser gehirn
nicht eigentlich sollten wir sagen
gestern um 9 uhr morgens hast du etwas
zu mir gesagt dass mich wütend gemacht
hat ich weiß nicht mehr was es war aber
es ging darum wer das brot versorgt
daher will ich lieber fernsehers von dir
berührt zu werden
eigentlich habe ich keine lust
fernzusehen aber ich bin verstimmt es
klingt seltsam aber so oft wird liebe
zerstört weil man insgeheim wütend ist
auf den liebespartner wenn es um liebe
geht sind wir verletzlich die kinder und
kinder werden wütend wegen kleinigkeiten
die man zu ihnen sagt als erwachsene
denken wir
ich bin stark ich lasse mich durch
kleinigkeiten nicht aus der fassung
bringen
aber in beziehungen reagieren wir nicht
erwachsen
da sind wir sehr dünnhäutig die kleinste
sache kann uns verletzen wenn sie ihren
liebespartner fragen willst du heute
abend mit mir essen und ihr sagten weiß
nicht kann uns das hier verletzten
aber wir wissen nicht wie wir das sagen
sollen um uns nicht lächerlich zu machen
ich musste bekennen ich bin ein wenig
wütend denn duschen gelang walter sieht
ihr sagte dass ich meinen kleinen finger
verletzt habe doch das scheint uns
idiotisch also sagen wir nichts
erstarren aber innerlich und das ist die
große gefahr
wir müssen zugeben dass etwas kleines
uns verletzt hat und einen sicheren raum
schaffen in dem wir das aussprechen
können
ich kann sehr gut verstehen was sie
sagen das klingt für mich so wie nach
einem modell von erklärung die
verkrustungen die entstehen die die
gegenseitige wut die sich hochschaukeln
kann die romantik die weg bleibt oder
die leidenschaftlich weg bleibt weil es
diese alltags verstrickungen gibt aber
es gibt ja auch noch einfach vielleicht
so etwas wie ein schlafender
leidenschaft sie selber
erwähnen in diesem buch wie man richtig
an sex denkt auch ein buch das sie
geschrieben haben
eher werden sie sigmund freud sie
zitieren in den sagen ihm sieben freude
hat das schon gesagt glaube 1912 wo das
so zu sagen wo die liebe ist ist das
begehren nicht mehr und wo das begehren
ist es keine liebe das ist eine
besondere herausforderung die sich
stellt wenn man längere zeit zusammen
wir erfahren als kinder was liebe ist
aber im kindesalter ist diese liebe
nicht sexueller natur zwischen kindern
und eltern darf es keine sexuellen
gefühle geben das ist völlig tabu dann
geschieht etwas merkwürdiges wenn wir
erwachsen werden und eine
liebesbeziehung eingehen kommen mit der
zeit immer mehr von diesen frühen
gefühlen zu unseren eltern aus unserer
kindheit hoch das ist sehr schön und
vertieft die beziehung es heißt aber
auch dass wir plötzlich die tabus der
kindheit wieder spüren
ich empfinde es immer als warnzeichen
wenn ein paar kinder hat und sich die
eltern plötzlich gegenseitig mama oder
papa nennen
und das auch noch wenn die kinder nicht
mehr da sind richtig problematisch ist
das weil sie sich nie erlaubt hätten zu
ihren eltern sexuelle gefühle zu haben
wenn wir älter werden ziehen uns
menschen die wir lieben sexuell an und
das ist eine sehr neue situation die
psychologisch schwierig ist
sehen sie ich habe eine tragische sicht
von gewissen aspekten die liebe
man kann nicht alle fragen beantworten
und es ist von nutzen wenn man anerkennt
dass es solche probleme gibt und es ist
sehr wichtig dass man die mutter und
vater rolle von der liebesbeziehung
trennen kann
deshalb gehen paare manchmal gerne in
hotels
es gibt keinen äußerlichen grund dafür
das bett ist nicht weicher aber man kann
mama und papa zurücklassen und somit
auch das tabu dass die sexuellen gefühle
blockieren könnte sie bringen hier drin
auch ein bild was mich ja was mich
interessiert hat sie haben an einer
stelle wir müssen lernen die perspektive
zu verändern dinge anders zu sehen und
zu bringen als beispiel ein bild von
etwa 1880 ein sparpaket oder ein spargel
bunt wie genau soll ich meinen partner
sehen wenn ich ihn sehe wie man sparen
gesehen hat was ist die neue perspektive
oft sieht man bei paaren die schon
länger zusammen sind dass sich eine
gewisse langeweile breit macht das
gefühl man kenne sich in und auswendig
schon bevor der partner zu reden beginnt
weiß man was er sagen will weil einem
alles vertraut ist eine lösung für
dieses problem findet sich
seltsamerweise in der kunst in gemälden
denn die geschichte der malerei ist die
geschichte von genies die alltägliche
dinge mit neuer vorstellungskraft
neugier und großzügigkeit betrachten
dadurch werden diese dinge die wir so
gewöhnlich finden plötzlich weniger
alltäglichen manne betrachtete spargeln
die wir schon so oft gesehen haben
genauer und sah wie schön sie sind und
wer sein bild anschaut entdeckt diese
schönheit denn man hatte den impuls
genauer hinzusehen ein anderer maler
malt ein flussufer eine wolke oder einen
apfel saison hat vermutlich ein
stillleben mit äpfeln gemacht wir denken
diese künstler sind eben genies nein die
welt ist voller wunderbarer dinge die
wir nicht wertschätzen weil wir blind
und verwöhnt sind und uns an vieles
gewöhnt haben also finden wir es
passiere nichts interessantes am meisten
haben wir uns an unseren liebespartner
gewöhnt er ist toll
als sie ihn kennenlernte waren sie
hingerissen das könnten sie immer noch
sein
das problem ist dass sie meinen ihn zu
kennen
doch das stimmt nicht sie haben noch gar
nicht begonnen ihn richtig
kennenzulernen sie kennen nicht mal sich
selbst
doch wenn sie beginnen ihn mit dir
vorstellen
kraft eines malers zu sehen gibt es hier
viel über das sie reden oder nachdenken
könnten aber nicht auch so dass das
genaue hinschauen oder die wie soll ich
sagen dass genauer studieren des
gegenübers gerade weil man in diesem
alltag gefangen ist und vielleicht auch
in einer langen geschichte in der es
verletzungen gab einen plötzlich den
blick frei legt auf dinge die man
überhaupt gar nicht sehen möchte oder
die man eben gerade nicht mehr in der
lage ist mit zärtlichkeit zu sehen
sondern die einen plötzlich nerven also
zb man fand es vielleicht am anfang auf
trac tief dass ein chaos zu säen auf dem
schreibtisch des partners weil man
dachte so bin ich nicht weil ja lässt
die sachen so liebevoll rumliegen nicht
mag dass wir die sachen da irgendwie
ihren ihren eigenen ihre eigenen ordnung
folgen und plötzlich mit der zeit findet
man es nur noch nervig und zieht es
nicht liebevoll sondern das genaue
studium führt dazu dass es einen nur
noch aufregt ist uns ja beim
liebespartner das an was wir bei uns
vermissen
sei es dass wir uns nicht als sehr
kreativ empfinden und dann geht man
kennenlernen der sehr kreativ ist und
uns daher fasziniert und das gegenüber
verliebt sich womöglich in uns weil wir
ordnungsliebend und rational sind
doch es kann passieren dass diese
anfänglich sehr positive seite beim
anderen und zu irritieren beginnt was da
geschieht hat mit der mangelnde
lernfähigkeit zu tun von dem wir
gesprochen haben
denn die beiden lernen nicht wirklich
von der stärke des partners der
ordnungsliebende partner hoffte etwas
kreativer werden zu können und der
kreative partner wollte etwas ordnungs
bewusster werden
doch das ist nicht passiert da hier die
irritation beiden ist es nicht gelungen
die stärke des anderen zu integrieren
zwei menschen werden aus guten gründen
voneinander angezogen aber dann müssen
sie lernen sich das anzueignen was sie
vom gegenüber lernen wollten die
chaotische person liebte anfangs den
orten sinn des partners aber sie
schaffte es nicht selber ordentlicher zu
werden obwohl sie es noch so sehr wollte
lernte sie es nicht
und schliesslich wirft sie den partner
genau das vor was sie anfangs so sehr an
ein fass
noch etwas anderes land es ist eine
theorie die ich die schwäche der stärken
etwas wichtiges dass wir nicht vergessen
dürfen ist dass in einer beziehung beide
ihre stärken haben
und wenn man die stärken genauer
anschaut sind alle mit schwächen
verbunden wenn also jemand sehr
ordentlich ist ist ihr wahrscheinlich
überpünktlich und jemand der sehr
fantasievoll ist kann nicht gute küche
reinigen
bei paaren passiert dann oft dass sie
nur noch sie schwächen sehen
das heißt dann deine stärken sind ja gut
und recht aber hier sind zehn schwächen
es ist jedoch ungemein wichtig zu wissen
dass fast jede schwäche mit einer stärke
verbunden ist die stärke ist immer noch
da aber man sieht sie nicht mehr
es ist also wichtig in die andere
richtung zu gehen und die stärke wieder
mehr zu gewichten anstatt nur die
schwäche zu sehen
die leidenschaft outsourcen also den
seitensprung sie meinen eine affäre
ziehen sie die affäre scheint eine
wunderbare idee zusammen
denn sie gaukelten vor man könne alles
in einem leben habe
die stabilität einer langfristigen
liebesbeziehung die aufregung eine
affäre und niemand hat probleme damit
das klingt großartig leider sind wir in
der realität schrecklich eifersüchtig
und keiner von uns akzeptiert dass der
mensch den wir so sehr lieben händchen
hält mit jemand anderem das ist äußerst
schmerzhaft und zerstört und ich denke
das sollten wir ehrlich zugeben und
gleichzeitig eine tragische seite
unserer existenz akzeptieren
wir können nicht sex liebe stabilität
aufregung und kontinuität gleichzeitig
haben man muss sich eingestehen dass
jede situation ihre
leidvolle seite hat wenn mir jemand
entrüstet sagt es ist widerlich wie
leichtfertig gewisse leute affären
eingehen sie sollten glücklich sein in
ihren beziehungen klingt das ihr
moralisch andere leute finden das ist
einfach lasst uns viele affären haben
leben wir doch polo amourös eifersucht
ist eine erfindung des kapitalismus die
brauchen wir nicht beide seiten meinen
es gäbe eine einfache antwort
doch es gibt keine einfache antwort denn
in beiden situationen muss man
schreckliche opfer bringen
man müsste sich eigentlich fragen wie
man leiden möchte wenn man mit einer
person zusammen bleiben und gute dinge
wie stabilität haben aber irgendwann
sexuell gelangweilt sein
das ist die leidvolle seite oder will
mal ein aufregendes chaotisches leben
ohne langfristige beziehung und dafür
unglückliche kinder
man muss sich immer bewusst sein dass es
keine problemlose lösung gibt es gibt
nur eine bessere oder schlechtere art zu
leiden was man auch wählt man muss immer
leiden wichtig zu betonen es ist nicht
so dass sie sagen es gibt die wunderbare
liebe ohne probleme aber es hilft schon
die probleme genau zu analysieren und zu
verstehen was genau ist das denn was
lernt der philosoph wenn die probleme
genau versteht etwas vom schmerz
vollsten ist dass wir denken wir seien
nicht normal wir empfinden uns als
seltsam
schuld daran ist dass wir uns nur von
innen kennen und von anderen nur so viel
wissen wie sie von sich erzählen
natürlich geben sie nicht alles preis
denn sie wollen ein gewisses bild von
sich vermitteln
wir wissen daher nicht genau was liebe
für andere menschen bedeutet also denken
wir was läuft schief in meinem leben die
anderen scheinen so glücklich zu sein
vor allem der valentinstag ist eine
tortur für uns alle um uns herum sind so
glücklich was mache ich falsch
die gute neuigkeit ist alle leiden wir
alle haben unsere schwierigkeiten weil
wir nicht ehrlich zu uns selber sind und
ich sehe die aufgabe die literatur darin
deshalb schreibe ich bücher über die
liebe das sie uns ehrlich
aufzeigt was in unseren schlafzimmern
passiert denn auch wenn wir denken wir
seien sehr aufgeklärt und ehrlich sind
wir das nicht wirklich
und obwohl wir nicht alles leid
vermeiden können leiden wir doppelt weil
wir denken wir seien mit unserem leiden
allein aufgabe die literatur ist es uns
zu zeigen dass wir nicht allein sind und
uns zu helfen die sorgen zu verstehen
die wir nicht aus der welt schaffen
können
sie haben ja auch ein buch geschrieben
trost der philosophie und man kennt sie
aus einem philosophen der sich ganz
vielen alltagsproblemen annimmt sie sind
ein bestseller autor in diesem bereich
würden sie sagen zu philosophieren heißt
immer zu verstehen dass man nicht
alleine ist mit dem problem für mich ist
philosophie an versucht zu verstehen was
das leben ausmacht also alles was im
leben eines menschen passiert von der
kindheit bis zum tod
normalerweise denken wir nicht gern nach
wenn sie zu jemandem sagen ich will dass
du allein in einen dunklen raum gehst
und eine stunde lang nachdenkst fragt er
bestimmt kann ich mein handy mitnehmen
nein nur du und dein verstand das behagt
uns nicht wir hassen es nachzudenken in
uns hinein zu horchen denn das macht uns
angst wir sind voller ängste sorgen
trauer und zweifel doch nachdenken ist
sehr wichtig sokrates die erste berühmte
philosoph sagte ein ungeprüftes leben
ist nicht lebenswert damit meinte er
wenn man nicht über sein leben nachdenkt
trifft man falsche entscheidungen leidet
mehr als nötig und versteht sein eigenes
herz und seine eigene denkweise nicht
ich wollte bücher über die liebe
schreiben weil sie uns so viele probleme
bereitet
ich habe selber oft deswegen gelitten
und den menschen um mich herum geht es
gleich wir können nicht alle probleme
beseitigen aber zumindest die problem
schicht entfernen die durch verwirrung
und ängste entsteht oder ganz einfach
weil wir nicht wissen woran wir leiden
natürlich sehr sympathisch aber es gibt
auch leute die sagen mir bedeutet das
nicht viel nachzudenken ich nehme
einfach genieße das leben es bringt gar
nicht sich über alles gedanken
eine person nicht auch glücklich solche
menschen gibt es aber ich denke unser
gehirn ist so kompliziert dass wir nicht
darum herumkommen
vielleicht kann man ein paar jahre mit
joggen übermäßigem arbeiten oder trinken
der beschäftigung mit unserem geist
ausweichen aber an einem gewissen punkt
können wir nicht mehr schlafen wenn wir
uns nicht damit befassen
schlaflosigkeit ist die rache für alle
gedanken die man tagsüber verdrängt hat
und die plötzlich um 3 uhr früh hoch
kommen unser geist möchte gehört werden
und das beste was wir tun können ist auf
ihn zu hören und für mich schaffen kunst
und literatur eine arena die uns zu
verstehen hilft wie wir sind
wir können das leid nicht abschaffen
aber wir leiden womöglich weniger mit
hilfe der richtigen bücher mit der
richtigen literatur ihr buch endet damit
dass die hauptfigur rabbi von sich sagt
er hätte den perfektionismus überwunden
er hat verstanden dass man nicht immer
alles perfekt haben kann sondern dass
man manchmal auch mit weniger zufrieden
sein muss ist das für sie so ein
erfolgsrezept generell im leben den ball
tief halten nicht zu hohe erwartungen
haben
ich glaube an hohe erwartungen aber man
erreicht ziele nicht durch intuition
sondern mittels strategien und lernen
ich glaube dass stufen zum glück führen
wir können es nicht mit einem sprung
erreichen sondern schritt um schritt und
mit solider planung am ende des buchs
gehen meinem helden dinge durch den kopf
die ihr wissen muss um richtig und
erfolgreich lieben zu können
dazu gehört die erkenntnis dass ihr ein
wenig verrückt ist ein feind der liebe
ist die annahme wir seien völlig normal
und gesund
rabbi erkennt dass diese haltung ein
hindernis für die liebe ist wer so denkt
ist selbstgerecht und rücksichtslos und
beschuldigt immer die anderen bravi
gesteht sich ein dass es ziemlich
schwierig ist mit ihm zusammenzuleben
wenn man das von sich denkt trifft
meistens das
gegenteil zu wir hingegen meint es sei
einfach mit ihm zusammenzuleben hat
bestimmt unrecht das ist die erste regel
wie akzeptiert auch dass seine partnerin
ein wenig verrückt ist damit hat ihr
leben gelernt denn er hat realisiert
dass alle menschen auf irgendeine art
verrückt sind
wichtig ist zu kommunizieren zu lieben
zu teilen den kanal des dialogs ständig
offen zu haben und unvollkommenheiten zu
akzeptieren
das sind einige die lektionen und sie
klingen sehr unromantisch doch es gibt
eine faustregel was nicht romantisch
klingt ist meistens gut wenn ich
jemandem rate ging mit deinem partner
essen und reden über alles was dich
wütend gemacht hat kommt sicher der
einwand es klingt nicht sehr romantisch
das ist ein gutes zeichen denn alles
unromantische ist wahrscheinlich sehr
romantisch im wahren sinn denn es ist
hilfreich fürs überleben der liebe mit
der romantik auf die wir doch noch halt
gerettet haben
ganz herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
alleine franke war mir ein vergnügen
nächste woche sehen sie hier den
berührenden film ursula der schweizer
filmemacher rolf ließ sie erzählt darin
die geschichte einer taubblinden frau
davor taucht mein kollege yves bost in
eine welt ein ohne farben und licht er
spricht mit thomas moser der seit geburt
blind ist und jetzt gleich geht es
weiter mit einem porträt eines klavier
spielers der auf den straßen des
zerstörten damaskus musik macht zwei
großartige filme heute und in einer
woche ich wünsche ihnen die zeit sie zu
sehen und einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]